[Música]
histórico Marruecos venció 1-0 a
Portugal y se convierte en la primera
selección africana en clasificar a la
semifinal de un mundial de fútbol un
deporte dominado por Europa y Sudamérica
su rival saldrá del Duelo entre
Inglaterra y Francia
la nueva presidenta de Perú Dina
boluarte anunció que espera que este
sábado juramente el nuevo gabinete del
país así como el nuevo premiere aseguró
además que visitará Castillo una vez
ratificado el gabinete esto en medio de
las protestas que piden nuevas
elecciones
este sábado Como cada 10 de diciembre
desde
1948 se celebra el Día Internacional de
los Derechos Humanos fecha en que la
asamblea general de la ONU adoptó la
declaración universal de los Derechos
Humanos que pese a ello están en
continuo riesgo incrementado por crisis
humanitarias y guerras analizamos
bienvenidos al nuevo informativo de
France 24 Mi nombre es Rodrigo sedano y
es un gusto acompañarlos abrimos este
informativo con noticias del mundial de
fútbol de Qatar allí Marruecos demostró
que ya hace varias jornadas que dejó de
ser una sorpresa hoy volvió a eliminar a
uno de sus vecinos ibéricos a Portugal y
ya está en la semifinal luego de haber
eliminado también anteriormente a España
lo hizo con un gol de nessiri poco antes
del descanso y es la primera vez que un
equipo africano clasifica a semifinales
de un mundial vamos a doha con nuestra
enviada especial Natalia Ruiz Natalia
cómo se desarrolló este partido y cómo
están viviendo los aficionados
marroquíes está Victoria histórica para
su selección
Muy buenas tardes pues es todo un gran
júbilo por parte de los marroquíes que
eran mayoría en este estadio aquí de
alsumama Gran jolgorio a lo largo de
todo este partido muchísimo silbidos
cada vez que Portugal tenía la pelota
Así que fue bastante ensordecedor Y
seguramente hasta un poco perturbador
para los jugadores lusos el poder luchar
por este partido a lo largo de todos
estos 90 minutos por supuesto ese gol
que llegó de Marruecos ya en el minuto
42 como usted bien lo decía Rodrigo de
Siri pero sobre todo es una falla una
salida en falso por completo de Diego
costa el Arquero de Portugal en el
segundo tiempo Portugal tuvo mejores
ocasiones sobre todo con la entrada de
Cristiano Ronaldo finalmente en este
partido Gonzalo Ramos quien había
marcado ese triplete en el partido
anterior en octavos Hoy estuvo
completamente desaparecido y fue Ronaldo
quien de alguna manera le entró a este
partido con un poco más de peligrosidad
más incisivo pero finalmente parecía que
lo escuchaban sus compañeros Portugal
estuvo luchando el partido hasta el
final pero pues Marruecos logró ya ese
gol y luego mantuvo la presión y mantuvo
una defensa férrea Ahora hay que decirlo
más Marruecos logra este momento
histórico por supuesto para su fútbol
para el fútbol árabe en realidad porque
aquí todos los Países Árabes van a estar
detrás de Marruecos en esa semifinal que
vendrá pero también Marruecos llega con
varios de sus jugadores al lesionados
entre ellos es ahí si quiera salió de
este partido lesionado y Bueno será la
gran duda vamos a ver cómo va esto para
las próximas semifinales esperando El
vencedor entre Inglaterra y Francia Ya
esta noche Natalia Muchas gracias por
este reporte estoy seguro de que muchos
marroquíes estarán esperando ahora un
enfrentamiento contra Francia vamos a
cambiar de tema y nos vamos hasta Perú
porque hay expectativa ante la
juramentación de nuevos gabinete
Ministerial de la presidenta interina
boluarte que asumió el miércoles tras la
institución de Pedro Castillo se espera
que los nuevos funcionarios sean
nombrados a horas del mediodía hora
local mientras Se confirmó que castillos
seguirá detenido luego de que la
justicia peruana declarara improcedente
la demanda de habeas Corpus interpuesta
donde solicita se disponga su libertad
inmediata vuelvo arte afirmó que
visitará Castillo una vez seguramente el
gabinete ampliamos desde Lima con
nuestro corresponsal Francisco Zacarías
Francisco la justicia peruana desestimó
la vía Corpus qué otras estrategias van
a ejecutar ahora
Rodrigo Buenas tardes los abogados del
expresidente Pedro Castillo acaban de
denunciar al Estado peruano ante la
Corte Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
y le están pidiendo
restituir en el cargo que fue depuesto
por el congreso de ese país luego de que
ejecutara lo que muchos peruanos llaman
un golpe de estado en el recurso la
defensa de Castillo le está pidiendo al
organismo supranacional que atienda la
solicitud de manera urgente
ampare la demanda y ordene la reposición
en el puesto a Pedro castillo de
presidente de los peruanos esto es
precisamente lo que hace unas horas
anunció el ex Primer Ministro guido
bellido que van a emprender una batalla
legal con otros recursos sin demandas
ante la justicia peruana y también ante
organismos internacionales
y Francisco que más información se
conoce sobre el posible nuevo gabinete
se han filtrado ya algunos posibles
nombres
bueno todo está listo en el Palacio de
Gobierno para la juramentación de los
nuevos ministros han ingresado algunos
personajes de la política peruana y de
las esferas del poder de los años
anteriores Y lo que hemos podido conocer
hasta el momento que los más voceados
para ejercer el cargo de Primer Ministro
serían el abogado Alberto tarana quien
ha sido ministro de ollanta humala del
expresidente ollanta humala y también
figura como defensor en temas legales
del ex mandatario Así mismo el ex
ministro de defensa Jorge Nieto sería
otro de los más opcionados Además del
embajador Luis chuquihuanca y el ex
defensor del pueblo Walter Gutiérrez acá
lo que se está pidiendo en estos
momentos es que Dina boluarte cumpla con
el ofrecimiento que ella dijo durante su
juramentación de tener un gabinete de
ancha base diversos sectores del país
están pidiendo a la presidenta Dina
boluarte que los nombrados ministros y
el Primer Ministro no sean personas
ligadas a algunos expresidentes o
administraciones anteriores Y que sea
gente nueva que genere confianza en esta
nueva administración y sobre todo traiga
la paz pero esta vivienda en estos
momentos un clima de desestabilización
producto de las protestas sociales que
se han desarrollado en diferentes
regiones del país han habido muchos
detenidos por parte de la policía y
precisamente la presidenta Dina boluarte
ha señalado que si bien ha habido
detenidos a todos ellos se les va a
garantizar el respeto de los Derechos
Humanos
Francisco Zacarías Seguiremos muy
atentos a lo que siga pasando en Perú
Muchas gracias por este reporte
cambiamos de tema porque el 10 de
diciembre del año 1948 la asamblea
general de las Naciones Unidas adoptó la
declaración universal de los Derechos
Humanos por ello cada año se celebra en
esta fecha su día internacional unos
derechos que pese a esta declaración se
encuentran en continua vulneración y
riesgo debido a situaciones de crisis
humanitarias guerras o contextos
políticos adversos según indica el fondo
de población de la propia ONU para
ahondar en esta problemática hablamos
con Jimena Reyes directora de la oficina
de Américas en la federación
internacional de Derechos Humanos Jimena
Reyes bienvenida France 24 si hablamos
de vulneración de los Derechos Humanos
por la guerra hay que hablar desde luego
este año de la guerra en Ucrania ha
provocado esta guerra un mayor deterioro
Durante este año y qué otros conflictos
no tan mediáticos preocupan en la
actualidad
sí efectivamente la guerra en Ucrania
es una situación sumamente preocupante y
dramática para los millones de
ucranianos que han tenido que salir pero
también para toda la región este la
primera vez en mucho tiempo que una
potencia como ataca agrede invade de
forma
tan violenta un país y eso ha causado
una gran estabilización en la región a
su vez hay otros conflictos un poco más
olvidados numerosos por ejemplo el de
yemen donde se tiene más de 200,000
personas que han muerto o la situación
en bienal en Asia o también
la reciente situación de conflicto en el
tigre en Etiopía
volviendo la mirada a la región
latinoamericana preocupa la situación
política en varios países como El
Salvador o Nicaragua Cómo ha
evolucionado la situación en la región
en estos últimos años
Sí hay un fenómeno muy preocupante
de deterioro de la democracia y en
particular por ejemplo en el caso de
Nicaragua donde se entró a una dictadura
con una violencia represiva
absolutamente inaceptable
hay más de trescientas personas que han
sido asesinados ejecutados
perjudicialmente en este momento
hay doscientos veintiuno presos
políticos y sigue el régimen de Ortega
Murillo deteniendo a personas porque son
de la oposición Porque eran periodistas
y inclusive ahora están definiendo a los
familiares porque no encuentran a esas
personas y y un siete el espacio
encerrado pues mil organizaciones
ocupacionales Pero además esta situación
hay un fenómeno en particular en
de deterioro o Guatemala Diamante y y la
gran afectación a la independencia de la
justicia donde han tenido que huir
Fiscales que estaban luchando y
denunciando la corrupción en El Salvador
con con la del presidente bukele
Entonces sí en la región ocupa mucho
esta este defecto Ahora hay que decir
que también hay algunas
situaciones de Esperanza no
Jimena Reyes Muchas gracias por
atendernos este sábado aquí en France 24
Muchas gracias gracias de nuevo y
cambiamos de tema porque fueron
entregados los premios Nobel y este año
se trata de una gala particular dado que
reunió a los galardonados desde el año
2020 que no pudieron acudir a recoger su
premio en persona a causa de la pandemia
de Kobe 19 el Nobel de la paz 2022 se
entregó a tres ganadores en oslo este
sábado o Alexandra Matt bitchup del
centro para las libertades civiles con
sede en kiev yan racchinski de la
organización rusa de Derechos Humanos
Memorial y Natalia pinchuck que lo
recibió en nombre de su esposo el
bielorruso Álex de la ong centro viasna
los actos de otros Nobel como los de
medicina física química literatura y
economía se celebraron en estocolmo
[Aplausos]
este premio pertenece a todos mis amigos
Defensores de los Derechos Humanos todos
los activistas cívicos decenas de miles
de bielorrusos que han sufrido palizas
torturas arrestos o prisión
este premio pertenece a millones de
ciudadanos bielorrusos que se levantaron
y tomaron medidas en las calles y en
internet para defender sus derechos
civiles esto es reflejo de la situación
dramática y la lucha por los derechos
humanos en el país
seguimos en Europa porque en Bruselas la
capital política de la Unión Europea
declararon este sábado ante el juez la
vicepresidenta del parlamento la
socialdemócrata griega Eva Cali y otras
cuatro personas detenidas ayer por
supuesta corrupción la policía judicial
belga las acusa de haber recibido
supuestamente cuantiosas sumas de dinero
y regalos por parte de Qatar con el fin
de influenciar en las decisiones
económicas y políticas del parlamento
europeo a favor del país del Golfo
además de estas detenciones la policía
confiscó material móvil e informático y
unos 600.000 euros en efectivo
y cerramos este informativo con la misma
noticia con la que la habríamos la
victoria histórica de Marruecos sobre
Portugal que le deja como primer país
africano en clasificar a las semifinales
de una copa mundial de la FIFA de fútbol
vamos a ver imágenes de las
celebraciones de los aficionados
marroquíes
con estas imágenes Nos despedimos les
invito a que sigan conectados a France
24 y France 24.com
[Música]